arriving in kabul by air is always
breathtaking
the scenery is spectacular the afghan
capital is surrounded by mountains it
can be a difficult landing even for the
most experienced pilot
the airport is large it's been
completely renovated by the
international community in the last 20
years
it was one of nato and the us's main air
bases before they pulled out their
forces in recent months it's now used by
civilian airlines and the afghan
military
and for the un and other aid agencies
it's a vital lifeline as roads have
become more dangerous supplies need to
be delivered by air from kabul
but now control of the airport has
become one of the most pressing
diplomatic issues
the us and other western embassies still
have large numbers of staff in the
country working in heavily fortified
compounds
turkish president recep tayyip erdogan
is offering to supply troops so the
airport remains secure and in a worst
case scenario can be used for an
evacuation of international diplomats
it's really important because the
airport is uh obviously the only way out
of the country and if diplomatic
missions are to stay in an afghanistan
that is going to be
administered at some level maybe in a
power sharing agreement by the taliban
then they
they need to be able to have a way out
if either a civil war starts or if the
taliban decide to gain more power and so
the
diplomatic activity of the country and
also the humanitarian aid of the country
is going to be decided by uh you know
whether the airport stays open or not so
far the taliban has flatly rejected the
idea of a turkish presence and i'm told
by diplomats that if a deal isn't done
soon the u.s is contemplating taking
control of the airport itself that would
be a breach of the deal it did with the
taliban last year and would complicate
things in this country still further
james bay's al jazeera kabul